foreign
good afternoon everyone my name is Dr
Miller and the SCP we're going to be
looking at today is SCP 6262
containment class esoteric secondary
class thou meal disruption class dark
and risk class notice
special containment procedures
scp-6262 inhabits the city of Daegu
Republic of Korea and as such the city
is to be considered its containment area
an ultra low-powered GPS receiver with
no less than six months of available
backup power is to be fitted to the
subject with appropriate methods for
recharging the power bank as necessary
the GPS transceiver is to maintain
unbroken contact with the foundation
monitoring station in central Daegu
which is to alert containment teams if
unusual behavior is detected Foundation
agents liaise regularly with
scp-6262 as part of the containment
procedures of other objects
reconnaissance normal debriefings and
other activities though should no such
opportunities present themselves for
whatever reason agents should maintain
contact with the subject at least once a
week
ordinary civilians who have held
conversations with
scp-6262 are not to be made aware of the
abnormal nature of their conversation
passengers disembarking the bus will be
scanned for possession of unauthorized
knowledge and amnesticized if necessary
they ate only one instance has been
recorded of
scp-6262 disseminating sensitive
information see incident 6262 1. no
Foundation employees of clearance level
above one are to Embark
scp-6262 without prior written
authorization from a level 4 employee or
higher to date
scp-6262 has shown a high degree of
compliance with the foundation and
forcible capture and or detention is
considered a last resort in the case of
acutely hostile Behavior or other risks
as they may present themselves
a 112 2017 proposal to revise
containment procedures rejected
by researchers Sorensen a 1 12 2017.
I know I just got reassigned to 6262 and
it's a lot to take in at first but we're
really just letting it drive around on
its own whip this thing represents Squad
a quarter of foundation off-site backup
in Korea regularly interacts with the
public and has the capability to Spill
the Beans whenever it wants and we're
just trusting it not to do that
I'm putting in a formal proposal to
revise the containment procedures on
file for 62.62. we can use it as an
on-site shuttle for site 19 or Pell one
of the Asian sites of it was
too much far far too much
reply Dr Cosmo Kemp
scp-6262 containment team lead all 113
2017.
it's been driving around for over 65
years now it probably knows just about
everything there is to know we've
demonstrated that a new state secrets
back in the 40s and there's still never
been any sort of information leak that
we can trace to anywhere near it
I agree with you that the containment
procedures for this object seem overly
lacks but it's quite honestly
self-containing it's better for us to
have a highly sentient mobile autonomous
and most importantly free method of
off-site backup instead of trying to
stuff this thing in a box like the rest
of them if it wants to drive in a circle
around Daegu day in Day Out
we're gonna let it
description
scp-6262 is an entity taking the form of
a bus or other means of mass transport
recorded since 1950 in various parts of
primarily Eastern Asia the subject
currently resembles a multi-colored
neoplan Skyliner bus with Daegu City
Tour printed on the exterior along with
images of unconfirmed origin
the bus is registered to the
tourism Association who retains records
detailing the purchase and ongoing
scheduled maintenance of the bus
scp-6262 drives a route consistent with
that developed by the tourism
Association driven by any number of
employees that seem unaware of the
subject's Sapient nature it has been
demonstrated however that
scp-6262 is capable of independent
locomotion
as of the time of writing
scp-6262 is known to have shape-shifted
six times all of them resembling a bus
of real make and model it is understood
through conversation with a subject that
it is capable of shape-shifting into any
form of transportation though prefers
buses as transporting civilians is one
of its pastimes this Behavior through
extensive analysis and testing has been
deemed safe and is to be allowed to
continue unimpeded
scp-6262 appearance log
location Hiroshima Japan First Dates
cited before 1945 appearance unknown
location Tokyo Japan First Dates cited
118 1950. appearance Keno Motors BH
location Petro Pavlov's kamchonski
Russian sfsr Soviet Union date first
cited 5-1 1962 appearance tralza ziu 5.
location
shizuoka Japan date first cited 613
1975. appearance Nissan UA
location Moscow Russian sfsr Soviet
Union date first cited 517 1983
appearance skoda t11
location nagada Japan date first cited
831 2013. appearance Isuzu turquoise
location Daegu Republic of Korea date
first cited 0812 2018 appearance neoplan
Skyliner current form
a general record of the subject's form
and whereabouts has been kept since its
initial Discovery in 1950 with
specificity and completion of archives
increasing as technology improves and
resources become more abundant at no
point in the subject's history has it
been considered a threat aside from a
minor Scare at the time of initial
discovery
the foundation initially became aware of
scp-6262 after folklore began to
circulate within Tokyo regarding a
friendly bus that shared polite
conversation with its occupants it is
thought that post-war improvements in
communication led to the subject's
Discovery a theory supported by the
subject's own claim that it had been
operating for many years and in many
places prior to its Discovery by the
foundation though it refuses to divulge
further information
upon entering
scp-6262 occupants will have polite
telepathic conversation with the bus to
a level that is comfortable for the
passenger people who do not normally
partake in conversation will report a
quick exchange of pleasantries while
those who tend to converse more deeply
report on discussing topics such as the
history of Transportation East Asian
culture with a particular focus on the
city in which
scp-6262 currently resigns popular media
and other topics participants generally
do not consider the telepathic
conversation abnormal and will refer to
it as a nice talk with an old friend or
other similar descriptions it is only
when made aware of the bizarre nature of
the conversations that participants will
begin to consider the encounter strained
scp-6262 is capable of absorbing parsing
and storing Knowledge from its
passengers including knowledge not
explicitly revealed to it the subject is
either incapable of or does not desire
to store duplicate knowledge and so most
knowledge Gathering within the last 10
years has primarily been about life
experiences instead of concrete facts it
has been demonstrated that the subject
does not know everything as it were
though its catalog of knowledge is
extensive consistent cooperation with
the foundation has led to the subject
status as a Fail-Safe Knowledge Center
fkc an archive to be used to back up and
store critical information in the event
of a k-class scenario as part of its
duties as an fkc
scp-6262 is permitted to store knowledge
regarding sensitive Foundation
operations accomplished by allowing
Foundation Personnel of high security
clearance level to board under
supervision
the subject has contributed extensively
to Foundation containment and testing
operations suggesting revisions to
containment procedures and pointing out
previously unknown anomalous properties
of cataloged objects in two separate
cases
scp-6262 has offered an explanation for
objects thought anomalous confirmed by
testing and led to the declassification
and removal of those objects
despite possessing knowledge of a vast
quantity of sensitive information
scp-6262 is maintained a near perfect
track record for not divulging this
information to unauthorized parties even
in cases where the subject's choice to
divulge such information might save
lives or ensure its own
self-preservation it has elected to
remain silent see interview snippet 6262
5A
interview
6262-5 timestamp 146 34 to 150 51.
playing log now
there we go
my elbow slipped from the window and
ended the recording no problem doctor
now I know we've discussed this topic in
the past but it's something I need to
have recorded for posterity the shot
callers are once again coming up my ass
wondering why we're letting you roam
about the street carrying an appreciable
amount of Highly classified
knowledge
knowledge pal at this point you probably
know more than I do so I can understand
their concern but I'd like you to tell
me more about the Manhattan Project to
set their mind at ease ah you keep a
secret and everyone always wants to know
why you kept it well
that certainly is the case I was
operating in Hiroshima in the months
preceding the atomic bombing and on the
day all is well
my route at the time as I was working
for the municipal Transit service took
me past what I gather was a house
inhabited by a U.S spy
thinking back I'm not quite sure if he
was a spy or some sort of Diplomat or
something like that but I do know he did
have a fair bit of knowledge about the
department of defenses activities at the
time
so from my usual hobby of knowledge
Gathering from this guy as he rode on my
bus every day I became aware of the
Manhattan Project and in the weeks
leading up to the attack the chosen
Target of Hiroshima I know he was aware
as well because the last I saw of him
was on August 1st
and you told nobody
correct why not
you could have saved hundreds of
thousands and I say this as an American
I don't personally have much of an
ideological opinion regarding the
bombings but if nothing else why didn't
you act out of self-interest
disregarding the question of if anybody
would have listened to a bus telling
them that their city was about to be
struck by some sort of mythical super
weapon I simply didn't feel it was my
place to divulge that information it's
not like it would have clearly saved the
world or anything like that it was a
question of the bad guys versus the good
guys
and I chose to spectate
end lock
[Music]
scp-6262 first came into possession of
classified Foundation knowledge as a
consequence of its effects when its
anomalous properties were first
identified Foundation researchers and
other Personnel in possession of such
knowledge upon first boarding the bus
report the subject as taking great
surprise and interest in the knowledge
it had gleaned from them and stopping
its route for six hours to filter
through the new information subsequent
conversations with the subject report
its great delight and willingness to
assist in operations should it be
allowed to learn more about the
foundation and its activities
by the time this effect was even
identified the subject was in possession
of such a wide breadth of classified
knowledge that any sort of informational
breach would have constituted a Breaking
of the veil information security
procedures have since been updated
accordingly
level 5 clearance required incidents
6262 1.
credentials accepted
incident 6262 1.
incident 6262 constitutes the only known
information leak originating from
scp-6262 the circumstances of the leak
allowing the subject to be forgiven
during a catastrophic containment breach
of SCP
a powerful computer-born Cognito Hazard
was disseminated across major news
websites social media networks and
the unprecedented strength of the
Cognito has it prevented containment
teams from adequately re-establishing
control and an emergency internet
blackout was ordered across Southern
Japan to prevent the further spread of
the effect
scp-6262 operating in nagada Japan
during the bridge was aware of the
credentials and access requirements to
impose the blackout but Foundation
employees on board the boss at the time
were too affected by the Cognito Hazard
to take appropriate action
the subject to recognizing the potential
impending catastrophe told the access
credentials and procedure to a civilian
who was on board at the time and
happened to have a high enough
resistance to the effect to adequately
access the computer network and impose
the blackout himself
after the largest situation was brought
under control the civilian was screened
amnesticized and released
scp-6262 was not punished for this leak
document 6262 2. staff note
posted by Dr Cosmo Kemp on o516 2019
[Music]
a stellar track record for the safe
keeping of foundation information
contributions to containment procedures
and other operations consequently I am
recommending that the subject's file be
reclassified from safe to thalmium
[Music]
okay
yeah this was a friendly bus
more Halloween appropriate SCP articles
will follow soon I just wanted to smile
today
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and you are all dismissed
goodbye
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to zargaron
big sip
oh crop guy
the Morrigan
James Saba
Irish wristwatch
Lost Boy
signor
your local Foundation agent
zazapan
worthy fire
Dr Wolf 13.
cubster
ding dingus
that loser
casadia cams
braided Peach
GM's right
Rowan O'Brien
cake neck
Grim near
extra moments one two three
armed Swift Raw
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the volgan
thank you
[Music]